[Música]
[Aplausos]
millonarios antes de los 25 de nuevas
empresas disruptivas de innovaciones de
nuevas tecnologías
tenemos institutos instituciones
universidades convocatorias etcétera
etcétera dedicados únicamente a crear
esta cultura del emprendimiento
y como tal vez algunos de ustedes muchos
de ustedes o gente que ustedes conozcan
yo también dije hey puedo hacerlo así
que decidí comenzar un proyecto de
emprendimiento y le dedique todas las
horas que me quedaban balanceando mi
vida personal mi vida en la escuela que
si la tesis que si la tarea y comencé a
entrar a todos estos cursos a todos
estos talleres a todos los eventos de
networking y decide entrar a un concurso
donde competir contra otras 200 grandes
ideas con mi proyecto al que yo le tenía
tanta fe
y durante un año estuve trabajando en
estos boot camps me peleé con mis socios
tenía noches sin dormir y fue todo un
martirio pero yo sabía que iba a valer
la pena y finalmente después de todo ese
año
obtuve el reconocimiento que yo sabía
que mi proyecto merecía
me nombraron como una de las mejores
startups de la competencia
sólo fue unos 14 de 200 y se hizo toda
una ceremonia me dieron una placa me
tomaron la foto las suyas redes sociales
y fue muy muy padre estuve muy muy
contenta
pero dos semanas después de esa gran
ceremonia
tuve que declararme en bancarrota
y puedo verlo en sus caras a ver
carolina qué pasó qué hiciste tan mal
que parte del manual no hiciste al pie
de la letra y créanme que yo también más
la pregunta por mucho tiempo estuvo
pensando en esto por tanto tiempo y no
encontraba una solución
en que había fallado que había hecho tan
mal
ya me había prendido todo el sat hice
todo lo de administración había
convencido a todos los jueces en que
falle
y de repente algo hizo clic
después de todo este análisis al fin lo
supe
y es que el sistema del emprendedor está
diseñado para que pierdas
y sé que suena chocante sé que no
queremos escuchar esto sabemos que el
75% de los emprendimientos en méxico
fracasa dentro de los dos primeros años
pero el 25% lo logra
y ser 1 entre 4 no parece tanto y
creemos que podemos lograrlo
pero el sistema tiene varios trucos y el
primero es convencerte de una cosa que
le llamaremos cultura del emprendimiento
comienza con frases genéricas como tú
puedes tú lo puedes lograr tu proyecto
vale la pena tu idea es buena pero luego
te comienza a decir otras cosas te
comienza a decir que un buen emprendedor
o sea ya hay buenos y malos que un buen
emprendedor es emprendedor 24/7
no hay descanso
te dice que necesitas tener la vida pero
organizada cada momento de tu vida tiene
que ir hacia la perfección
te dice que si tus amigos tus compañeros
y tu familia no está lista para
acompañarte hacia el éxito tendrás que
hacerlo solo y más de alguna aquí será
culpable como yo lo fui de seguir estas
redes sociales que se dedican
exclusivamente a mostrarte de estas
imágenes todo el tiempo a poco no nos
queremos sentir inspirados nos convence
de que la vida godines es pecado
que no podemos ser godínez y que si lo
somos es solamente de manera transitoria
cuando ya seamos emprendedores cuando no
tengamos jefe cuando yo sea mi propio
ejemplo
te convencen hay que explotar te es
realizarte
y una vez que hace eso no te dice que
existen dos categorías de emprendedores
que si bien no son determinantes si
influyen mucho en tus posibilidades de
ser parte del 75% que falla o del 25%
que lo logra son los emprendedores que
sí tienen recursos y los emprendedores
que no
el problema está en que los
emprendedores que sí tienen recursos
muchas veces se pararán tal vez no aquí
pero lo han visto se parará en frente de
ustedes y dirán a mí nadie me dio nada
yo soy como tú yo soy la mayoría tú
puedes
pero ver raúl tienes 29 años vives con
tus padres tienes un título
universitario eres una minoría de una
minoría de una minoría
el préstamo con el que empezaste tu
emprendimiento que pasó al 25% en
realidad te lo dio tu papá no tienes
idea de que son intereses hasta ahora
que ya tienes el dinero
y si acaso eres de la parte que no tiene
recursos que logre ser parte del 25%
sólo hay dos opciones o fue una
excepción y no debemos compararnos con
excepciones por salud
o no tenía nada que perder
y me dieron todo
por la urgencia y la necesidad ahora yo
me consideraba parte de los que si
tienen recursos
soy una persona que siempre tuvo una
educación de muy alta calidad en
colegios privados tengo a dos padres que
me apoyan solo tengo una hermana con
quien compartir estos recursos tengo un
título universitario incluso tengo un
título de postgrado claro que tengo
todas las herramientas para ser una
emprendedora parte del 25%
pero de lo que yo no me estaba dando
cuenta era que el emprendimiento me
estaba quitando recursos que yo estaba
dando por sentado recursos que yo ni
siquiera sabía que tenía y es que el
emprendimiento puede ser un vampiro
chupa almas que te quita toda tu energía
y todo tu bienestar y es que emprender
es una apuesta y la casa nunca pierde
porque incluso si logra ser del 25 por
ciento tu meta
comprobado va a ser que alguien más
venga y te compre la idea
tú trabajas te metiste todos tus
recursos todo toda tu energía y ya qué
comprobaste que es una buena idea ya la
posición hazte y ya la pasaste del 25%
al 25%
entonces viene alguien que siempre tuvo
todos los recursos
siempre lo estuvo y bajo la excusa de
que no tenía tú idea viene y te da un
cheque y tú tomas tu cheque muy contento
y crees que todo valió la pena pero no
hay cheque que te devuelva tu bienestar
no te lo puede garantizar no hay
reconocimiento y no hay placa que te lo
dé
sé que para muchos emprender es un sueño
y no estoy aquí para decirles que no lo
hagan sino para darles las herramientas
necesarias de saber qué poner y que no
poner sobre la mesa
quiero que tengan todas estas
herramientas para que juntos viendo este
sistema que es evidentemente injusto
podamos trabajar para cambiarlo
y la manera de hacerlo es reconocernos
primero como personas
que nuestro valor como personas no
depende de nuestra producción económica
y que fallar no es malo
fallar es humano y no hay nada más
maravilloso que ser humano gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]